let me just listen to my block
[Music]
hahaha
lights up for washington heights up at
the break a day i wake up and i got this
little punk i gotta chase away
pop the break at the crack of dawn sing
while i wipe down the awning
hey y'all good morning
cherry strawberry and just for today i
got my mate oh yes
i am us you probably never heard my name
but parts of my fame are greatly
exaggerated
exacerbated by the fact that my syntax
is highly complicated cause i immigrated
from the single greatest little place in
the caribbean
dominican republic i love it jesus i'm
jealous of it and beyond that
ever since my folks passed on i haven't
gone back
god damn i gotta get on then oh
the milk is going bad hold up just a
second why is everything in this fridge
warm and heavy
i better step it up and fight the heat
cause i'm not making
any profit if the coffee isn't light and
sweet
abuela my fridge broke i got cafe leche
hey dios try my mother's old recipe
one can of condensed milk nice oh hey
your lottery ticket
that was abuela she's not really my
abuela but she practically raised me
this corner is her escuela now
you probably thinking i'm up i've never
been north of 96th street
well you must take the a train
even farther than harlem to northern
manhattan and maintain
get off at 181st and take the escalator
i hope you writing this down i'm gonna
test you later
i'm getting tested times are tough on
this bodega two months ago somebody
bought ortega's our neighbors started
packing up and picking up and never
since the rest went up it's gotten mad
expensive but we look with just enough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rosario he runs the cab company he
struggles in the barrio
see his daughter nina's off at college
tuition is mass thief so he can't sleep
everything he get is matching good
[Music]
morning
oh my god you're so excited i nina flew
in at 3 a.m last night sweet
[Music]
it smells like one of those trees that
[Music]
sunny you're late chillax
you know you love me me and my cousin
running just another dime a dozen mom
and pop stop and shout and oh my god
it's got it
hot like my man cole porter said people
come crew for a few cold waters and the
lottery ticket just a part of the
routine everybody's got a job
everybody's got a
dream they gossip it's nice if my coffee
is smurf the first shop is people hop to
work
169 i got it you want a box of condoms
what kind that's two quarters
two quarter waters the new york times
you need it back for that the taxes at
it once you get some practice at it you
do rapid mathematics automatically
selling maxi pads fuzzy dice with
taxicabs practically
everybody stress yes but they press
through the mess bounce checks
what's next
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
i'm making deals but guess what what
still ain't got no skills
[Music]
no no
[Music]
it's not reflected in my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well your coffee's on the house
[Music]
[Music]
is tight and you're stuck to this corner
like a street light
yeah i'm a street light choking on the
heat the world spins around while i'm
frozen to my seat
the people that i know i'll keep on
rolling down the street but every day is
different so i'm switching up the beat
because my parents came with nothing
they got a little more ashore with paul
but yo at least we got the star
and it's all about the legacy they left
with me it's destiny and one day i'll be
on the beach with sonny writing checks
to meet my heights
we came to work and to live
this is the block
[Applause]
every day every day
right then washington heights